thank you very much so thank you
everyone for coming to see me it's
pretty happy to see everyone interesting
on this topic well just a one minute for
myself my name is ko and I work for free
now but it's basically this mobility
calling taxis but as you can see there
is nothing related to my actual project
what my actual work is this is a side
project and my intuition today is to not
come up with a new technique machine
learning models or deep learning for
performance wise what I wanted to share
with you all those steps that I've been
to when I wanted to use a case that I
had interested so I want I play music I
wanted to try to predict some chords for
my music and I also got interested in
how I could learn this technique called
hidden Markov models so I just used
combining this you interested through
interests and came up with these
projects as a side project and do not
expect super high performances but my
expectations is for you is to just
follow up in the learning process and
maybe you can even use the concepts that
you learned today for the projects when
you go back to your work maybe you can
see that this can be applied in the same
fashion way so as I found out the
internet might not be so good so
meanwhile downloads you can have the PDF
on the link on on github I will start
out in a notebook here but as soon as
everything is finished everyone can
follow along so let's just start here
bloating so I'll do a lot of talking
this is because of this projects is a
little bit new for me I think it's a
little bit complex as well I didn't want
to try to have so many risk of life
coding so I'll try to talk a lot but if
you're everyone is interested to go a
step deeper and try to understand the
functions that I have written all the
functions that I have obstructed because
I just wanted to show the logic or the
line of thoughts all the functions are
right our roads are on this YouTube
folder so you can see how they were
built there or all the more technical
details today I'll go more in a
conceptual wise or how to think about
hidden Markov model is how to think
about modeling a problem with that
so let's start out so basically as I
said this problem started with me I play
guitar and sometimes I see that I see a
music on you I hear the music on YouTube
or a SIA music someone playing music
somewhere and I really liked it I really
wanted to play with my friends or at
least for myself and even a search on
the internet I cannot find the chords I
cannot take the guitar for myself and
play the music so why not think about ok
maybe I can join I feel the techniques
that I want to learn I would like what I
want
alright No and what if in a hypothetical
scenario we could just send the youtube
link just somewhere or I could just
upload this sound music my mp3 file or
youtube link to our web sites and you
would return to me all the chords or
mainly the main course that has been
played in that music so I could just
play along I could follow along so this
is the main motivation this is the main
context that I started with
you know tribute this project and I end
up coming for just a small pipeline and
this is what I want to go through today
so basically we will talk about what is
sounds here for computers so if I want
to start out as input data having a
music signal my mp3 file or whatever and
at the ends have some good chords
predicted so I could play with it this
is the more this is more or less the
pipeline that we go so we'll see how
musics represented will see the main
technique that we are going to use in
order to be able to extract features
that are relevant for my problem on
chords recognition it goes a little bit
on Fourier transforms and at the ends
the main features that are you gonna use
is called chroma grams I'll go over them
and this one they will go as the input
for the way modem I hit the mark off my
hidden Markov model so when I go here
this is the main call that I want to
explain about each day because on the
Internet's if you want to find out how
this to work you can actually search and
median papers archive or somehow but
there's a few things that I didn't find
it easily because they were hidden
behind some really crazy mathematics so
my main idea today speak about these
probabilities in a easy way so you
everyone can understand the logic try to
understand the logic behind it and try
to understand why it was it was it uses
and finally just a small step again is
about just evaluating what the hidden
Markov model has produced and how can we
evaluate it somehow can we appreciate
already in terms of sounds can we have
an understanding in a statistic way what
is the quality of the sound that has
been produced it and this would be the
final block so as it starts we always
have to make the questions okay so what
is the kind of input data that I'm
working with and here I'm showing I'm
just reading a sounds and it's basically
a piano being pressed so let's just take
a look how this sounds looks like here
the sound is louder than that so it
seems I don't have sounds here so I
would ask Alyssa to make the sound for
me please don't just upload to the
maximum volume thank you for your work
so what does this sound does look like
in my computer so this is basically what
is this sound when the key was pressed
and this is the sounds going on tune
time so x axis we have the time and the
y axis we have the amplitudes it's a
kind of a mapping way to represent
sounds in terms of sound wave pressures
so if we take this signal and we give a
quick zoom inside so more specifically
for this point five two point five fifty
five seconds you're gonna see that's how
this sounds actually quite different
from the beginning so this is basically
the same signal that I showed before but
zoomed in in a point five point zero
five seconds and you can see that even
though it doesn't seem inside is pretty
periodic so it's basically a periodic
sight signal that's over time of course
it changes its dynamics but if you look
quite in a quite small time window is a
quite periodic signal so the reason I'm
saying that is because I need to come up
with some technique somehow that will
bring me to closer to my objective of
producing and now relevant features to
understand which chord has been played
in that song or in
case is a pretty simple sounds it
doesn't apply but it's just an
introduction so the technique that we're
gonna use is called Fourier
transformation
you're gonna step by step so the first
thing that we want to the stand on this
transformation is you basically try to
understand what its main fundamental
components that were used to build the
sound that we are seeing here so what do
I mean about main components were the
the most basic components whenever we
speak about sounds or signal processing
will speak about sinusoids so the main
for your transformation try to
understand what are the all sinusoids
what are the main most simple
frequencies that I could add up in order
to have this signal that you are all
seeing here basically that is a
transformation so it will take the
signal that we have we can take another
example here Alyssa can you play the
again sorry so this is just this is an
example to show what happens with the
Fourier transform this is the sound of a
whistle and this is the signal that I
have if I upload the sound to my
computer and this whistle is a nice
specific notes in terms of the pitch in
terms of the frequency so this a five if
we search on the internet this notes a
five corresponds a specific frequency
that corresponds to roughly eight
hundred 80 Hertz so when I go and take
this signal I apply my Fourier
transformation this is what we have so
it will tell me now the x and y axis
will have changed so before it was time
and amplitude and now we will have
frequency and energy so the frequency is
what as our main goal is try to
understand what is the main components
that build to that signal and the energy
energy would be the loudness the amount
of that frequency that we have present
in that signal and because it's a pretty
simple signal I'm doing it with a simple
signal first we can see that the main
components the peak here is around the
component that we expect around 880
Hertz so this will be our main forum or
B or may approach for the technique we
will try to understand what the
frequency that makes up to that sounds
and with the three
we'll try to understand what course has
been played but we have a one specific
problem that falls into one of the
technicalities of the Fourier
transformation so when when I took when
I take this transformation and on the
mathematical way the Fourier
transformation will look at the whole
signal doesn't matter if it's 1 seconds
2 seconds or even 30 minutes and try to
say okay given the whole signal what are
the main components what are the main
frequencies that are used in order to
build that and for us in our case
because you work with music I don't want
to do that I don't want to lose this
kind of information of I won't
understand what are the frequencies that
were in the beginning in the middle and
then the end of the song so what is the
problem this is an example of the
problem for the Fourier transformation
is that if I have a sounds which changes
over time Melissa so this is a person
with ly different notes over time and
this is the plot if I take the whole
signal and do the Fourier transformation
with that kind of sounds we know that
the person has with so different
frequencies different notes but can I
say that this node happen at first what
this node happened second third and
fourth I cannot so if I'm one of my
music I don't want to play it through my
signal to the computer to predict the
chords and the computer shows me a list
of course and I have no idea which one
to play first so a way to come up and to
take advantage and also have this time
domain information on a signal maybe we
can take the whistle that we have done
instead of calculating the Fourier
transformation in the whole signal we
can maybe split it up so make small cuts
on it and in each one of these windows
why we can call Windows each one of
these splits we can apply the Fourier
transformation so with that we will have
the frequencies that make up to the
small first window second window third
window until we come up with the whole
signal and the technique just this
technique just this change to make
Fourier transformations on small
time windows is where the name of the
technique comes up so this is just one
step in advance where is it this is just
one step in advance of the Fulvia
transformation and it's called short
time Fourier transformation so it's the
four-year but apply to each one of the
windows so if we look at this plot here
now you can see that we have the time
dimension and we have the frequencies
and the color basically means the energy
how much of that frequency is there and
then we are able to see the sequence E
of whistles that has been played can you
play again a little please
and you can kind of have the intuition
of what were the notes that were played
and we actually can see the dynamics of
they're not going up going down and
going up again for us for a longer time
so this will be a great advantage for us
if you want to see the sequence of note
that has been plays because that's what
we want right and but again everything
here that has been shown is on notes I
don't want to predict whistle notes I
don't wanna project you piano keys press
I want to give a whole song so on the
song we have guitarists playing the
whole all the strings of instruments you
have drummers we have best players
playing everything so we need to
understand not only the frequency that
is being played we need to understand
the whole possible notes so if I if my
guitar is is playing a chord which can
is called like C major chords and it
this C major chord is made up with a lot
of notes
not a lot but with more than one notes
so this is the step that we have to
understand just a little bit before so
if you want to do this short time
Fourier transform I want to do in a way
that's relevant for my chord recognition
system and I can understand which chord
has been plates
so basically chords any musician here
okay you guys can help me if I say
anything wrong but cores are basically a
set of notes it's not a random sort of
but it's a specific sequence of notes
that can help me understand so I can
have a pleasure pleasurable sounds for
everyone that's Siri or notes they have
different functions but in the ends is
basically a set of notes so when I do my
short time Fourier transform I will get
all the frequencies that happens that
happens in that short time window all
the possible frequencies so has has in
this small window do I have an ASA on a
notes or B notes C notes and more than
that in in the way we in the way we
created the the system notation for
musics I don't have only one a note I
can have one a notes I can have an A now
it's in a higher pitch
ain't no it's in a even higher pitch and
the system's goes forever but if we
think on the chords and I want to say
okay this guy in this moment has been
playing in C major chords I will don't
care if they were playing this lower
pitch a or this mid-level pitch a or the
high pitch a what I care is okay how
much of the notes a is inside this in
this side this window so this is the
last transformations that we are going
to do to the music signal before using
it as features for a hidden Markov model
and because we don't care which a has
been played I can basically take the
output of the short time for hear
transform let me let me go back I can
basically take the output of this and
whatever this frequency means in a
higher pitch mid level lower level I can
sum them up because from your cares is
how much shaders on it and if I join all
these frequencies what I can have as
output what I can have as output is this
kind of plots so this is what we are
going to use from this music signal
anyway this is called a chroma gram the
chroma gram is similar to the short time
Fourier transform we have the x axis
that's been the time and on the y axis
instead of having the frequencies I add
everything up and instead of having few
cases I have the notes names so
basically saying
how much of cenotes I have on this how
much of G de and for each one of the 12
notes that we have at least in Western
notation so we can have an idea how that
works can you play this song Alistair
this is just the intro of a music from
the billows the bitters will be the main
goal that I'll be working with here
today because there are Goods and I like
them and if you don't like it well sorry
but can you play the Lisa please okay
so beautiful song and ensure everything
clean just a piano should be super
perfect for at least for this scenario
so what happens is that I took that
sound and I calculated the chroma gram
at least for that intro and you can see
that the dynamics are pretty much well
detected so we can see that our hard
trash holds basically as barriers here
on the chroma gram and that means that
when the person changed the chords so we
can see that on this first moment from 0
to 1.5 seconds roughly there was a lot
of C notes and if you go to website if
you go to try what does the court that
has been played for that 1.5 seconds is
a similar chords there's a sum of the Y
notes there's a little bit of G there's
a little bit of B and on this case trust
me these are a few good set of notes for
the C major chords or C major seven
minor in this case this okay this I put
as a an extra material oh sorry there's
an extra section at the end of the
complete notebook because it's a pretty
I thought it was a more advanced topic
to discuss with but I can't discuss at
the Q&A for sure of the of my intuition
not doing the time resolution if that's
fine yeah there is some theory so a bit
in Schwarz I want to detect the smallest
step from a semitone on my Fourier
transform so I have to understand what
is the minimum time window from my short
time Fourier transform that can detect a
half semitone of time or frequency
resolution yeah
we can go after for sure so so we see
here there's a c-note egb and afterwards
there's a change of course so you might
be thinking okay maybe I don't even need
the hidden Markov model for formal
recognition problem maybe that is easy
that is so it's just look at the bottom
whoever is the lowest pitched notes take
it but right after this second right
after this first chords the C chords if
I look he I just searched for it
the second chord is not a D chord
actually is a G major chords so that
happens because courts don't have to be
s don't have to be played the notes of
the chords don't have to be played in
sequence E and in music we actually have
a name for that which is called an
inversion so I instead I play the chords
and instead of playing the roots notes
as the low as the lowest pitch I just
played one of the other chords so it's
actually not that easy to just make an
assumption that the notes that has more
energy is actually the representative of
the chords so we need something more to
understand and try to predict a little
bit more smarter in a smaller way what
is the quarter has been played and
actually one of the things that makes
Western at least in Western music
notation is that each chords that I play
at least in my music they have a certain
function they work in a certain way to
make you feel relaxed to make you feel a
little bit more tense to make you feel
like oh the music has finished or no the
music is not going to finish now
something has something going to happen
and that actually really good and a good
really good inputs as a feature for us
where if we try to predict so as a
motivation to try to use Markov chain we
have to think about that so if I play
the C chord and then I play the G major
chords there's a really really big
chance that the follow up chords would
be either C major or a minor and that's
because a music theory that's because of
how many and how many is western music
works and we can use this information so
if I'm trying to predict this course of
this time window what has happened in
the past window what has happened in the
previous chords and we can use that
together with the chroma gram and then
at the end project what they calls
play now so this is the main entry for
us to talk about Markov chains so I was
this is our board music signal
processing that's what I want just to
skim over and now I will talk about
Markov chains but just does someone has
any question until now so if no one has
any questions I can just try to answer
your question but can you repeat just to
make sure I understood okay so the time
resolution for that just repeats for the
recording the question was what is the
time resolution that I use for my short
time Fourier transform and after a few
derivations I shown a notebook but I
used a point 24 milliseconds time window
so it's a pretty short time window
because I want to be as loose as
possible in terms of changing dynamics
in change of changing of words and I
want you understand that okay this has
changes so does this answer yeah yeah
because in Fourier transform we have a
frequency resolution problem so in the
if I use a choose small time window
I am not able to detect changes in
variations in frequency so the reason I
chose this point 24 is because the
minimum frequency resolution that I have
is able to detect a semitone in terms of
frequency if I use this a short time
window smaller than that I wouldn't be
able to capture I changed from C to C
sharp let's say cool okay so enough
about go on a hwadam as if I have to
make a new window for the frequencies no
so in order to choose what is the lowest
frequency resolution that I wanted I
took the lowest notes and that a human
here could hear so from us the lows you
know that someone can hear for a c-sharp
there's a small change in frequency
there and this is how I try to the
find my window resolution what's the
last question just to make sure that we
have time yes I didn't use it because I
don't know it's I'm honest I'm
interested there's actually interest if
you have time afterwards but yes I
thought about that but okay so enough
about signal processing so just a
summary I am interested off on the
chroma gram and I want to know what has
been played in the pot in the recent
past because this can help me together
with my chroma gram to do a better
prediction on the chords so here the
best-case scenario that we can use at
least at the smaller first vault for me
is about Markov chains or Markov model
so say I use both names so what are they
this is a really good way to represent
sequences so as have practice before we
can say that Markov changes this state
as a state transition system and when I
say States if we represent each one of
the chords that I have so let's say if I
look at some music let's say a look at
lady B the whole music and I look at
some already created someone someone
already created the chords and I can
just take a look okay the Paul McCartney
has has played the C major chord C major
chords one note has been he has played
afterwards we can see that okay after C
major he played a few times F major
sometimes a minor sometimes G major and
if I count every single time that he
trials he went from one chord to another
and then afterwards just analyzed so we
just we can have probabilities this is
what you see here this is what you would
see here we can see that if you're not C
major if I just throw a coin I could go
for each one of these states a minor D
minor G major F major or even go to the
end of the music and I would see what is
the probability of going to a C major to
a minor C major to a d minor and so on
one thing be interesting for example we
can see so if in the music I see a G
major chord and the next chromatogram
looks like a D minor because my Markov
chains say
no there's no way to play a G major and
afterwards a D minor my Michael Chang
would say okay
probably even though it looks like the
next one next chroma Graham looks like D
minor the Markov chain would say no
that's not possible because I know from
the transition from my state machine
that's not possible so that's why this
sequence II it captures really well what
is the possible sequence that I can have
but as we have talked into you now we we
have discussed we can look at the past
data we can look at some old songs from
The Beatles and all the annotations they
have or the chords that has been played
in order to build something like this
but when on my own this project the main
input data is not about the text of the
course itself I have a music signal I
have the chroma Graham I don't have this
kind of infrastructure here so basically
what we say in terms of in terms of
concept is I have a state machine
running in the background stating what
is the probability of going from one
chord to another in in the music but I
actually cannot see it because the only
thing that I can see is the signal is
the music signal or after all the
pre-processing is the chroma gram so
because of this matter this is what I
want to predict the sequence of chords
and this is what I actually can observe
and because the fact that I cannot see
this this is the only change from a
Markov chain to form a Markov model to a
hidden Markov model it's literally
because it's hidden the only thing that
I can see is my observations it's my
chroma gram or my music signal so okay
we went from the features we went to
want to use on Markov model for sequence
during the stand sequence promise yes
yeah yeah it's literally built from
historic historical data so if my story
call data for some bad luck doesn't show
that that's not my Markov chains gonna
be and exactly I'm gonna talk about that
the last step because I had some hammers
on my system and more or less because of
that yeah so okay we have Markov we have
a Markov model we kind of understand
what is the probability of being from
one car to another but the only thing we
see is the observation so how do I
connect how do I work with this so my
code model is a good hidden Markov model
is 1 2 which is already quite
established and unfortunately is hidden
behind some heavy mathematics but here
what do you want to know what do I think
what you need to know after trying a lot
to understand what is actually useful
not we need to understand three kinds of
probabilities so what we going to do
here which is the biggest part the
heaviest part is trying to understand
the three tools that are hidden Markov
model needs and in order for you to work
in order for you to be able to predict
or in this my case new chords but you
can be whatever you're working with and
it's actually good because I don't need
to go into details of how the prediction
is gone is done we can discuss
afterwards because this three tools is
what we need to to call a framework so
we are gonna use a framework from Python
called hm and learn and this is a this
is the parameters that the package needs
in order to be able to produce a
prediction so first one chords
transition probability matrix this one
we already have from the Markov model
this one is what we cannot be change
from past historical data
I look up a bunch of music I look of all
the chord transitions that happens in
the music I normalize it and then I have
my transition probability matrix yes
yeah I'll go down in this next section
and this is what we have then we need to
come up in a way to connect my
observations with my Markov chain
because I need some way somehow to
connect okay I saw this chroma gram I
saw this time window and I needed to
connect that somehow to my Markov model
and these are called emission
probabilities and we'll go over that
Lisbon at last we need to calculate just
because of the mathematical formulation
we also need the small probability
matrix that says okay the music hasn't
even started what is the probability
that I starts for each one for a sim
with a c-major with a dream major so
this is called literally initial state
probability matrix the first one we have
taken a look
the last one is quite intuitive and
literally is just for that purpose to
start the prediction and we will take a
look mostly at this a mission to ability
but then it that's a valid question in
theory everything works but again I have
a music signal the music signal doesn't
have labels doesn't have which chord has
been played so how do i connect how do i
how am i able to first search which call
has been played and second how am I able
to connect my observations with whatever
chord has been played in that time
window so for that luckily there are
some people who spend a lot of time
producing a few datasets and in this
case was not different so this is a work
from this guy from heart and he did a
PhD work in trying to understand a few
things about music and music information
retrieval and all his work in his work
he evaluated together with all the
musicians and together with all the
scientists 120 musics from the Beatles
they evaluated this song the version
right the studio version which year
which album that was and also labels
from its second suite seconds which
court has been played so at least this
can work for us as a really good gold
standard because we can use that as the
notation we can have the music files
somehow works if temperature connects
and then luckily for us we have just
supervising supervising a machine
learning problem so let's go to it let's
see if I secure Vivian before
so the reason why the taco fire is
actually quite big because I try to make
it easy to download the music's for all
the repo deaths hardly has done but I
also have to have I also have to do a
lot of pre process in terms of naming of
the music's matching the song with the
annotations files then I decided to
upload this file to the github that's
why the github is actually so big and my
sorry for that but there's a folder
called labs in music in the repo and it
contains pairs for all the musics so I
have around 50 musics all the 50 muses
containing the signal mp3 file and the
lab which is the annotation so the
annotation is literally this it will
tell from each moment to which moments
in terms of seconds what cord has been
plates if you look at it there's some
hidden secrets here going on behind so
there's a read and simplify chords
because two things chords are actually a
little bit subjective it can go a little
bit of an emotion of who is it who is
listening to it and maybe the guitar has
playing one chord and the bass has play
out and the second guitar played another
so there's a lot of interpretation of
what is actually the chord that's being
played there and chords has can be
really complex I showed just a two
examples on C major or C minor for
instance but it can be really really
complex and what I've done here on the
reeds and simplify I resonant D
annotations and whatever the complex
chords that hard to set the pillars was
playing I converted them to the simples
form as major or minor chords because I
want to see my Markov chain just working
as a first so we take few feats take a
look at this function but at the end
we're going to work with major and minor
chords here so here so here I have the
annotated starts ends and because I
wanted to see again the Markov model
work in everything that I'm doing here
is just with one song so I'm trying to
do all the pre-processing with one song
and at the end if everything goes right
at the end
do everything so I get the song I get
the annotation I get the song I
calculates how much of each notes so
from C to B how much energy of each
notes I had in each one of my time
windows so did these columns is all the
signal processing for the first section
about calculating the chroma gram and
the last table sorry the last column is
just a joint from the annotations data
sets so I could know in that time window
given this signature of energy I know
that they were playing a C major chords
so if you look at this this is already
something that we could work with
because each row here can be seen as a
row of features we have 12 features for
each one of the notes we can ignore the
starts and ends we could ignore the
temporal dependency and we have the
label so I haven't tried actually I
don't know how much good or bad it would
be but it's a matter of interested that
it could be for next steps so I could
use twelve features and the label would
be one of the cords
the D plates but we want to have fun so
we want to work with the hidden Markov
model as a motivation so we have the
data sets and then we go for the first
matrix that I want to calculate so this
is what you have seen before
state transition matrix the probability
of going from one chords to another and
what I've done here is I took each one
of the windows and I calculated what is
the I counted how many transitions
happening from one chord to another
normalized it so I could have
probability so I could have probably
probabilities and this is what I've done
here so because as you see as you saw
you have we have small time windows here
we have a lot of chords so if a chord
has been played for maybe three four
seconds these chords is going to appear
a lot of times because I have just small
time windows so because of I have
a lot of repetitions of the same chords
you can see this search high values here
because there's a lot of tendency that's
okay because it's an E minor in a time
window some the chord just last for too
much time there's a lot of a minor in
the sequence this is a decision that
I've made when modeling I could try to
create transition probability matrix
just looking at the annotated data sets
instead of looking at time windows and
this is something that can be done
afterwards as a testing but that's okay
we have looked we have calculated the
probability of going from one chord to
another this is the first matrix matrix
I will go back to this emission because
we're gonna spend a little bit more time
on that and I calculate also the initial
state probability matrix just see if it
works
yeah the initial state probability
probability matrix I ran through all the
notations files I looked at the first
court and then I normalize this so I
could have initial state probability so
that's pretty straightforward but now we
go to the hardest parts if you search
for emission probabilities so
probability of that time window that
small time window of my signal have B as
C major chords or beer D minor chords or
be whatever chords
it's called emission probability it's a
way to connect my observations with the
Markov model but if you search on the
Internet's if you go for hidden Markov
model in median archive or whatever your
gonna see explanations like this so this
is what I want to explain before and
we're gonna say that it's not exactly
the problem that we have at least for
called recombination problems so when we
look at emission probabilities and we
wanna calculate so I want to give an
example there's a little bit more
simplistic of the quartz we will
generalize for the cores afterwards but
let's just change your minds a little
bit here
and trying to predict what is good
what's probably can what can be the
weather based on a person's reaction or
personal based on the person's if it's
if he's happy if he said so let's say
for example
Juana predicts what is the probability
that I see this person happy given that
it's sunny outside or on the opposite
what is the probability of this person
being happy given that it's rainy
outside so this is the same intuition
for emission probabilities what is the
probability of seeing that observation
given it is in certain states so when we
look at this we have actually this kind
of situation where my observations are
categorical one so if I have a
categorical observation
he's either sad either happy maybe
they're neutral whatever it's still
categorical it's still just a set of
lists a set of it items when I have this
it's easy to calculate the mission
probate probabilities because I can just
count I can look at my basic I can look
at my past data and I can see okay how
many times I saw that this person was
said and how many times it was sunny how
many times it was rainy so I look he was
said a hundred times he was it was sunny
outside for a hundred times four hundred
times it was rainy outside if I
normalize my probabilities dividing by
the total counts this is my emission
probability so if he said there's a
point you probably probability that is
actually sunny and point eight
probability that is rainy and we can do
this for all the states sorry for all
the observations said neutral or happy
and that's basically count so that's
actually easy and that's what you find
everywhere on the internet when you
search for hidden Markov models and
emission probabilities but if I try to
do the same on my problem oh let's go
one step at a time actually let's say
that instead of having happy sat on
neutral I have the temperature so what
is the probability of instead of being
sets what's the probability of
temperature equals twenty point seven
given that it's sunny if I'm trying to
count all the possible distinct values
we can have this we can have an infinite
count so probability of temperature
equals twenty point seven given an sunny
but I also can find
examples where temperature equals twenty
point zero seven or find all the
situation when temperature equals twenty
point 0 0 7 and so on so when my
observation is continuous it's actually
not feasible to make counts to do simple
calls on categories and bets because
it's as a continuous variable I cannot
just count them so this is about the key
moments that how can I do that for my
problem because if you think about the
observation from my problem from the
chord recognition problem is a set of
numbers is not a category I have the
amount of energy for each one of the
notes from my time window so the count
wouldn't work so how we do it how do we
say what's the probability of
temperature equals 20 given that it's
sunny in order to do that we have to
make assumptions and it goes for the
modeling approach that you do but if you
look up if you think about we actually
do it pretty well based on our past
experience so if I say if I come to
someone and say what is the water in
Brazil so I'm from Brazil I would say
the story on this so in summer days in
Brazil the they usually tends to be
between 30 and 40 degrees so I have an
estimation I have a prior assumption or
what's the number will look like given
some criteria given that it's summer
given that it's a sunny day outside but
if I speak about winter I'm not so much
different a fortune so winter is
basically some a summer day that didn't
work so we have temperatures not lower
than 15 and 225 so given the keep the
key idea that I want to make here is
that we make assumptions so we can make
assumptions given this knowledge we can
make assumptions on this kind of
calculation so if I tell you if you tell
someone here from Brazil what is the
probability of temperature equals 40
given that in sunny he won't know the
number what he would say I'm pretty sure
this probability is higher than if the
weather was rainy or if it was winter so
this is works just because of these
assumptions and this is what we are
going to do
on this example and then generalize for
the cog recognition problem
as humans we cannot say probability of
that equals 0.7 43 we just can make just
a few directions but here for the chords
recognition problem we want to say given
this chroma gram of a lot of numbers I
want to state exactly what is the
probability of observing that this is a
C major chords this is a G major chords
and the way to do that we have besides
assuming the how the chords how the
nodes would look like for each one how
the notes would look would look like for
each one of the chords we also have to
assume a specific probability
distribution because I can say okay when
I play a C major chords I'm pretty sure
that C E and G nodes will be a super
high energy because that's how the C
major chord is built and they would have
an average value in terms of energy and
because I don't want to be super
restrict I would say they can also vary
a little bit so if I look at my chroma
gram I see the biggest nodes are CEng
depending of how lower or how bigger or
how higher these energies are I will
have some like fats in order to say even
though if there's a little bit this is
probably a C major he on the other hand
if I see a GD e notes I will have some
prior assumptions because I have seen it
before that this is probably a G major
chords and this is how we're gonna work
here for the chords you're gonna make
assumptions of how on average each one
of the energy of my notes from a chroma
gram looks like for a given chords so if
you remember well we have a whole data
set here is just one music but we will
have a whole data set of where each row
is a time window
and we have the label so what we can do
is let's start with C major note C major
chords take all the rows that have a C
major chords and calculates the mean
energy for each one of the notes and the
variation the standard deviation of
variance for each one of them even that
I basically create signatures for each
one of my cards for a signature card I
have some in energy for each one of this
and some tolerance so I have some
variance information about each one of
the energies so with this I can
calculate my probability of observing a
chromatogram given that its imager I can
see oh this is my chroma girl this is my
first time window and given this
signature I can calculate the
probability of this being a C major G
major a minor and so on so basically we
managed to creates or connection between
observations and chords or in this case
states from the Markov chain did we
manage to calculate the emission
probabilities this was actually the
hardest part so this calculation and and
oh that's C so we have reaction okay we
applied this for the this is how we can
apply this for all chords and chroma
grams so we calculated or three main
blocks for hidden Markov models and we
also look at a little bit of signal
processing so we only have the last part
of joining the pieces together create
predictions and try to evaluate it but
before that does anyone have any
questions okay
don't know if that's good or bad but
let's go if it's I hope everyone is just
waiting for the ends okay so we have
everything we have the features we have
the matrices and we can complete our
speed up because we have I think no much
oh no I think we have time I calculate
my emission probabilities here I hope I
did my initial stage that I had
calculated before and this is the main
parts so this book there's no much
secrets what I use here is a package
from Python is a framework called codes
of h h mm oh here
hmm learn so this package obstructs a
lot of things for me even though it
doesn't seem so but when I calculates
all these matrices
there's you I have in mathematics that
happens behind the tool so I can make
the prediction but hopefully with this -
I don't need to worry about how the
calculations are done I basically needs
to create my hidden Markov models and
this states that I'm working with normal
distributed emission probabilities so I
just did that this is an object where my
emission probabilities we have an
assumption of normal distribution and
what I have to say is since the
transition probability probability
matrix some parameters that this is well
this goes one step in a more advanced
topic but when I work with
multi-dimensional data set our multi
dimension features I cannot I can
calculate the average value of all the
nodes I can calculates how much more or
less the energy varies for the cenotes
over a denotes and so on
but I can also calculate their
dependency I can also calculate how much
the C note there is together with a
denotes together with some other notes
and if you think systole this is a term
of or covariance how much my number is
how much my features varies with another
one and here I say that I say that's
full because it's the way I calculated
my covariance matrix for from the
emission probabilities so we create the
object we set the values this is the
initial state probability matrix this is
a transition for ability matrix this is
the average values from my emission and
these are the variances or covariances
for my emission probabilities as well
calculated everything we can build it
and hope and let's execute it and then
we can have our predictions here so what
happens is this prediction what I did in
this prediction I got the model I got
the chroma grams and quartz remember
from one song from one part of the ladee
be sunk
which is actually super clean piano solo
which hopefully could be super goods
in order to I trained with that data and
I also predicted with that data in this
first case so I wanted to see actually
if the tool works I wanted to see if
whatever I assumed in terms of
distributions emission probabilities
worked as a prediction as creating a
model that creates predictions the
reason I do that is actually I put this
as a post from it's not related to
hidden Markov models but it's actually a
good technique when you try to
understand whether certain architecture
works so i builded a hidden Markov model
but it also valid for neural networks
that you want to work with or let's say
this complex deep narrow deep
convolution neural networks or LSD aims
a good thing that you can see that okay
did my architecture works is try to
overfit is try to make your model
predicts exactly in a small piece of
data sets if that works I can have some
strong assumption that if I try to
generalize for a bigger data sets that
will work so that's the only reason that
I try to do okay simply with the
smallest piece of data with the most
simple one and okay I predicted and
again this is a multi-class
classification problem so I won't put
them up too much moments here because I
think we're gonna hear thousands of
talks on evaluating machine learning
models the way evaluated them is true
f-score so multi class we can now
evaluate sum over all F score from all
the classes and this is just a visually
visualization that I found it's cool but
we can see given the cords this is the
time if it's green it is because the
machine the the Markov model got it
right if it's black it's because it said
it was a it was the C chord but it
actually wasn't and you can see that the
biggest mistakes even though it's a
simple date again there was a few small
mistakes in the chords transition so
when it turns it in translate from C
chords to C major to a G major the model
takes a few time windows to adapt to the
new data showed after the chord change
in the chroma gram and let's see how it
stayed
so what happens here so my mother
produce predictions my mother produced
predictions and remember that I'm
producing predictions for each one of
the time windows pretty small time
windows like 0.5 milliseconds what I did
here is just a small pre-processing step
where if I see too many caught too many
predictions of the same class together I
just join everything and also say okay
you had a bunch of C major chord
predicted from these moments to these
moments so I just joined in riffing up
this will make my life easier because I
would show this data to a package called
simplify MIDI it's a way to give in a
given that you have your data you can
create MIDI sounds like simple starts on
a computer and then I can try to
simulate what my model has predicted
what my model has produced so let's take
a look at Lisa so if you could press
like the super advanced data science
methods can you press two buttons a
little bit faster that's fine
the meat is a little bit advanced yeah
that's fine that's fine
so because we saw here because we saw
the model did pretty well we could have
an idea of the F score and we could have
an idea of the visual evaluation that's
dimana did pretty good
of course I taught ompletely over fitted
probably if I did any other song it will
be super awful what is already the
motivation is a motivation thing yeah
it's good it helps you to spend more
time on there it's okay I managed to do
over one small overfit a small data sets
lets you ignore the super big step let's
try to predict the whole song and
instead of taking the intro I would take
the whole song so a big a big question
mark is what will happen when they start
to sing or what will happen when the
German explodes the how you call
the plates I don't know symbols yeah so
this is a big question what if what will
happen and unfortunately on the I know
it works here okay so we switch we can
see that now I tried with one song
trained and projected with one song the
F scores already know that thought that
motivating and this is what I what kind
of a spoiler that I want to show it and
I talked to the beginning at the end
it's a little bit not super average the
model but it's still kind of funny to
hear what has been produced try as fast
as possible no wait
[Music]
there are some small mistakes here from
the model super bad mistakes
[Music]
he will stabilize someone moments
[Music]
okay I'll save you I'll save you some
time so it gets super good in the
beginning you get super beautiful but
they're the only reasons that it's a
beautiful one-person piano playing it's
just one simple instruments and whenever
we have some more instruments or
whatever have some more vocals the the
sounds the signal or consequently the
chroma Graham gets pretty messy I'm not
even talking about a noise I'm even
talking about the instrument itself so
in music there's a lot of concepts for
harmonics I don't know if you guys then
if you heard about it but whenever I
have an instrument and I play one note I
actually don't produce the simple
Fourier transform that you saw in the
beginning of one simple frequency I end
up creating a whole bunch of frequencies
just because how the string oscillates
and these kind of movements actually
creates a lot of difficulty for the
model yes that's actually a good points
I haven't tried but yes so what I have
done actually I didn't explain there's a
good points when I did the Markov chain
when I did the Markov model that I
explained here I took only as a relevant
historical data only the exactly last
moments so what was the chord that I've
played exactly one time window ago in
order to predict the next one but his
question like why did I take why didn't
I take more time windows before that
could help me that would make me a
little bit safer in say which court
could that be and that's a good point I
haven't choice but I can believe in
terms of complexity will increase a
little bit as well but of course there
could be a next point for to try it out
there's a good mode there's a good
comments and at the end we produce I can
produce I produce the pipeline oh I
forgot to say about that so basically
created all the functions that you saw
in each one of the cells above I like
concatenated them into a set of a little
bit higher level abstractions
and at the end we can just call the
train pipeline with the list of songs
the path of where the song is and it's
gonna do everything that I have shown
you until now
so I did that for one song for the
letter B and I could do that for all the
songs I have 50 songs in this this
github repo I hope that's legal to be
honest but you guys you can take please
don't sell it okay but you can take and
you can try to process it you can try to
understand how the transition
probability matrix is I won't do that
here because takes a little a little bit
of moments I didn't care about
performance at home so this is a little
this is really slow but on the PDF I
have saved the execution and at least
the outputs of it
so actually 50 songs I trained the
hidden Markov model with 25 of them and
then I predicted with 15 is like a
validation set for each 115 I calculated
all the chords that are on the all-time
windows calculated f1 score put it on a
list and calculated the histogram and as
you can see it's not as really really
really oh I'm Billy I'm being super
hopeful here but it's actually bad it's
actually bad but again I wanted to show
the whole process the whole line of
faults here and actually when trying to
predict with all the songs and looking
at it at the predictions there was a
little that was a lot of cool
information that I could get you know
that should try to do a second iteration
and we go here for the last parts in
terms conclusion in terms of conclusion
first conclusion yeah it sucks now but
we can do it better so what the model
has done or what are the main mistakes
from my model that I could at least
understand then I can make from a second
iteration so first of all we have some
situations that as you can see when the
person starts to sink or when
specifically when I test with all the
songs when there's a lot of drums the
the chord prediction stays really really
bad so one of the things that we can do
is
what if we just removed the drums so
there's a technique in signal processing
that fortunately for us there's a
package really famous for that does
anyone knows about liberals oh yeah I
see some yeses yes yes so it's a really
cool function to process signals in
general and they have a framework that I
can just use a function called harmonic
percussive source separation or H PSS
for shorts
I showed my signal there and given a few
hyper parameters I can give I can have
it with just one two lines of codes a
pretty good source separation among
drums and the harmonics or the harmonic
instruments at least do you can you just
try to execute one last sorry for them
go to sounds play a harmonica let it be
and go like to the mid of the song so
this will be this version of the song
which where the drums or where the
percussive sounds has been removed
oh why we do that so how does how does
it do that
it's okay it's a little bit roughly but
it works in the same way as we worked in
the beginning that I will take the
signal I would take what are the main
frequencies with a short time Fourier
transform or with a Fourier transform
itself I have some waters usually the
frequencies that correspond to the
instruments and hits corresponding
harmonics I can take that and filter
that out if I do that I can actually
separates from my signal the harmonica
Sherman's at the percussive ones yeah
into the middle of the song
oh nice okay
so trust me on this it's it is
interesting but yeah I think you can see
on the github repo I hope when you
download it you can execute it has
someone managed to download the report
[Music]
and you can see that there's no drunk
almost no drums on that I think that's
the soul is gonna start now right okay
thank you so this is what we just want
two lines of code from the Liberals a
function can you execute the percussive
if you manage to go to the same exactly
moments because there's a lot of jumps
on then it's not a super perfect job but
consider these a bunch of lines of codes
it's pretty amazing
okay thank you so this is one of the
things that it could be done as a second
step as I know that the drums really
damaged my prediction why not remove
them vocals I also would be another
story also would be another good
positive points but when I started to
search for vocals for separation it's
actually way more complex so I don't
even put that as a second interaction I
would wait for some PhD developer guys
to develop that for me second one Oh
actually skip the second one third one
this was pretty interesting I look
towards giving Accords what was the if
the model made a mistake what would the
biggest mistakes on that and I found it
pretty interesting that the model will
make a specific kind of error that's
really interesting for music theory
perspective so as an example a lot of
the moments that I was playing see major
chords or the Beatles playing C major
chords my model would say this is an E
minor does it doesn't anyone sounds any
interesting that so basically a music
theory you have some conditions of how
them how that chords are separated and
because of some tea
properties of how we buttes these notes
similar chords and a min a minor chords
actually have the same set of notes so
that's why the modal gods really really
confused and what happened afterwards is
that because of my transition
probability matrix when they motivate
the innocent mistake of predicting the a
minor instead of a C major all the
follow up sequence notes all the follow
up chords were made for okay what
happened when the billows actually play
a minor so it would perpetuate the error
so a good interesting thing to do here
that I found it because the model made a
mistake of doing a C major doing an E
minor but for some bad luck there was no
returning from a minor to C major so I
didn't actually allow the model to fix
their own mistake so what we could hit
what we could do here we could make okay
relative minor which is the name of this
property from the music I can actually
manually change my transition
probability matrix go to each one of the
relative minor from each one of the
chords and it allows some buffer allows
some probability from my mother to go if
they make an ascent mistake allowed them
to come back to the original chords so
they don't put the perpetuate the error
so this one will be asked for an
interesting thing to do sorry a C major
that's true that's true that's true
actually no no this is the 6th degree ok
I will think about that so it don't get
stuck but that's true I don't think
about that I think that's I think that's
the point yeah that's true thank you
very much and yeah that and that's C and
lastly I took all the bit of songs all
the fifty ones that I had and I true
that into my hidden Markov model in
order to build transition probabilities
you know distributes admission
probabilities but you think about
transition of chords if a song is at a
certain key there is more chance that
all from one car to another so if I
think about if my music is on a C key
it's actually quite possible that I
transit from a C notes or C car to be
chords but the same thing just because
the way the scales are built but if my
music is only is let's see what doesn't
have yeah if there is a one key note
that doesn't have these notes one key of
the song that doesn't have these notes I
could actually calculate different
transition probabilities for each one of
the key each one of the music is but
that would also increase my complexity
because if I wanted to predict a new
song if I ever found a new song I would
have to see and check out algorithms to
understand okay what is the key of this
song so I can use the correct transition
probability from my predictions this is
all this also interesting I think on the
browser they also already have this kind
of small functions to estimate
I don't know how precise they are but I
think you should show a small piece of
song they can try to say okay this is
probably a music on C on the major or so
on
finally I created a list of predictions
I can I actually I even created the MIDI
files but as a in the beginning of the
story I wanted to have an output that I
could play with it myself I could take
my guitar and play with it but this is
not relevance for the hidden Markov
model parts but let's say we have the
predictions let's try to scrape the
lyrics let's try to scrape where the
beats or let's try to understand where
the beats of the song happened because
usually chords change depending on the
bits and then try to fit the chords to
the bits if I managed to do that I could
create some spreadsheet or not
spreadsheet some PDF that would output
for me lyrics that I scraped from the
Internet's where the mode of things
stood where the chords change in terms
of beats and what is the qualities as
predicted so in the near future which is
really really future we could do that
and maybe or Knights could be saved for
because of Helaman
and thank you does anyone has any
questions let's start here yes so the
question is because music is not only
depending on the past the quote the
current card doesn't depend on the past
but also in the future if I could use
bag of words but how could I use the bag
of words in this in this case if I
managed to incorporate the time
dimension on this word counts I think it
could be a possibility
but and this is the first thought when I
calculate bag of words it's go more or
less the Fourier transform I lose what
is the order of the chords or what is
the words that happen it's just yes
that's a good question so if Vanessa
correctly just repeats is we have two
sorts of informations we have
data the past chroma Graham and we have
informations from transitions from the
course itself from the Markov chain
Markov model so how can I wait then
somehow which one should be weighted
more so this goes on how the Markov
model among the hidden Markov model
creates the prediction itself so this is
a presentation a book but if you go to
the complete if you go to the complete
one there's a lot for more informations
that it would take a lot of more time to
cover on the last section I go through
what is the intuition of how the
prediction is being done behind the
scenes so I - I have you put every
probability matrix to the hmm package
and I said predicted but what has
happened in the ends what is happening
behind the scenes and if you look about
it Markov chain
they don't predict sequentially they
don't predict this chroma gram and then
this one and then this one it would take
the whole sequence and that's gonna say
given my sequence of observations I
would try a bunch of sequence of chords
this actually no what happened was a
little bit more intuitive what is the
sequence of chords that maximize my
overall probability so let's see here so
the final sequence of course that I have
is actually the sequence that maximize
this probability of what is the most
probable chords given observations if
you break it down like this is just bay
is breaking down the equation trying to
make a few assumptions but this is the
breakdown of the two different sources
that you have so this is about emission
probabilities and this is about Markov
transition probability so in the ends
you take the whole sequence and you try
a bunch of C chord sequence and just
check which one maximizes this
probability and you can check the
equation that you on this notebook it
will make more sense if it's a little
bit more complex but that's why I didn't
cover it so completely here
oh no but it's a good point
like I haven't think I haven't thought
about anything around it into house
dealing with inversions but what what do
I expected I saw some chroma grams
I saw the energy of my notes and
although my chroma gram would indicate
like in the beginning oh this is a D
even though it was a G but I expected
that from the sequence from the past
sequence and from my transition
probability matrix
somehow my Markov chain would understand
that we saw that that delay exactly
happened because of the results but so
then it would be one of the extra
features like consider the hell up
relative miners considering everything
this is actually a good idea for extra
feature for the hidden Markov model on
the annotation annotated data set from
the Beatles it's a lot of chords and I
made a lot of simplifications to try to
see at least a few poor kids yeah yeah I
can I only have 50 songs I might be
arrested because I share with everyone
so I need a bigger bigger data set and
just think about how to do workshop with
that anyone else on the back
[Music]
yes so the question is how does the
model deals when there's only single
notes being played so for instance in a
solo and honestly because the model have
the full objective of given that window
given the chroma gram predict the chords
one out of the twenty four like minor
major minor and sharp and flats so there
are two moments where the model just
doesn't understand one is when it's
single notes the other one which is
silent so with if it's silent the models
say you have to predict something here
and a cool way to maybe try to deal with
that if we interesting to deal with
uncertainty so the model can say I think
is at C major money actually not sure
but is actually a problem I'm sorry he
was so the question is wouldn't it be
enough if I only use the chroma gram to
predict the chords and you're right
you're absolutely right so when I
calculated the chroma grams and join it
with the I know
data sets so we have crime agreement
cords and label I actually thought about
that so maybe I actually don't even need
this this tool but my purpose here was
to was twofold
so one just try to join some to that I
want to learn with the interest that I
have in music and try to do something I
haven't hadn't done before but I'm
really really interested if I stopped at
that moment and maybe just chew into a
logistic regression just range a simple
thing that could classify the chords and
check the F score and I had the answer I
I don't know but I'm really interested I
haven't tried but that's a good point
you have is we always have to try to be
as simple as possible but in this case
was the interest of learning that so
itself just now a you right so the
question is is if there wasn't any way
for me to treat to deal with silence
there is for sure I would say I haven't
done it much work on it myself but let's
say if I have it managed a way to smooth
down all the noise and the future like
if all they start playing still the
chroma gram would show something just
because of noise just because of some
mic problems electricity or itself but
of course we could make maybe some
smooth down and say hey do not predict
on this chroma gram that should be maybe
enough like predict this come on girl
oh but then you have a point that if I
predict this as silence I have to embed
that into my transition probability
probability for the next chords so I
haven't thought about that but so we
would maybe is it possible but I haven't
fought fully about that okay
yeah I will talk to you afterwards then
to just get the name of this tool but I
haven't seen it that's quite interesting
does someone else have any questions
well okay I'll be here in the conference
for the old days if you ever have any
questions or want to talk about music
next types things that could be done
I'll be happy to hear happy to do it
some thank you
[Applause]